Here's what I think is happening. Now,
I'm not a prophet. I'm not a prophet.
I can be mistaken. I'm just seeing and
observing and I'm coming to what I think
are informed opinions. If I'm wrong,
Lord Jesus, have mercy on me because I'm
not saying I'm right. This is just
something I think. Take it or leave it.
May the Lord Jesus save us from error,
stammering against sin and hate sin, and
never blasphe Lord Jesus Christ. Please,
Holy Spirit, fill us to walk worthy of
Jesus. But here's what I think. Exactly.
Ancient aliens. Ancient aliens is
happening. Did you know, by the way,
even the late Michael Heiser believed
aliens were real? Michael Heiser wrote a
book, The Facade, a novel where he tells
you aliens are real, but they're demons.
So, there are Christians, credentialed
scholars like the late Dr. Michael
Heiser. A lot of people don't know
Heiser was an expert on UFOs. And he
believed that they are demons, the
watchers of Enoch and Daniel. Do you
know that? So, you'll be shocked how
many credentialed scholars believe they
exist. But Heiser, because he was
biblically informed, knew they were
demons, the watchers of Enoch, the
fallen ones. Okay, now here's what I
think is happening. Damn, I got the
wrong coat there. Poison. Damn it.
If they are now being public, here's
what I think is going to happen. If it
happens, glory to Jesus Christ for the
wisdom he gives us. If not, Lord have
mercy on us.
I now foresee
a huge
catastrophe.
Something's going to happen. Either
there's going to be World War II where
the world will go through a huge
catastrophe,
lives killed, maybe me and you,
lands destroyed,
putting mankind on the brink of
extinction so that the demons will now
appear as our saviors. This is what I
think is happening. This is why now
they're being upfront about it because
they're preparing you for the demons to
appear.
They're preparing you for the demons to
appear. So you're not afraid. You don't
see them as demons. You see them as
extraterrestrials who are so advanced.
They love us and want to come and help
us and save the planet. But what happens
is something catastrophic has to occur
where mankind is on the brink of
destruction and they step in. In fact, a
lot of the testimonies, you know what
they tell you? You'll find UFOs
showing up at strategic military bases
and nuclear power plants. That's what
you'll hear from
intelligencia.
They will tell you that they see a lot
of UFOs appearing in strategic military
bases and nuclear plants. Is that a
coincidence?
Is that a coincidence? Why are they
appearing there?
I think what will happen and if it
happens, God forbid, because it happens,
we can die. Now, we die, we'll be with
the Lord Jesus Christ, and we'll return
with him. We have nothing to fear. But I
have daughters and I pray they're
trusting in Jesus Christ, my Lord. I
don't want them to suffer, but if they
suffer, the Lord is worthy. We all
suffer for him. It's easier when you
suffer than see your children suffer.
But here's what I think is going to
happen.
Okay, here's what I think is going to
happen and then we're going to begin. We
can talk about I can open up a Q&A if
you want. We can defer Sabil to another
time. I'll put the link. If it's
questions, we'll do questions cuz I got
about an hour and a half, God willing.
Here's what I think is going to happen.
Okay?
Because Revelation, I believe, is yet to
be fulfilled. A lot of it was fulfilled,
but a lot of it is future. And the
Revelation clearly says a third of the
world will be destroyed, right? Okay.
So, I really think something
catastrophic will take place. Maybe
Russia, China, Iran and there may be
even a nuclear
holocaust. Maybe something is happening,
something is brewing. These wars,
Russia, China, Ukraine, America,
something is taking place to lead
mankind to the brink of extinction
in order now to make men desperate for a
solution. And that's when the aliens
show up because they're supposedly more
advanced than us and they can help us
advance and they will be looked upon as
our saviors. And voila, the one world
leader arises from them.
If that happens, Jesus is at the door.
Yep. Chuck Mistler also confirmed that
he believed they're demons. In fact, not
only that, I keep forgetting their
names. I don't know their names.
Okay. I don't know their names, but I
watched the documentary where it was
stated the two leading experts at
aliens, they were not Christians.
They studied cases and they both
concluded independently. And you can do
a search, put two leading UFO experts
conclude
and they concluded independently from
each other. These are not
extraterrestrials. They're
interdimensional.
They're from another dimension, not from
the universe, i.e. demons. And they're
evil and intendous harm.
Two leading experts in the 20th century.
After examining these cases, they
concluded, and they're not Christians,
by the way.
They're not Christians. This is my
opinion on UFOs. I know from scripture
they're demons. Yeah. Kodesh, can you do
me a favor, guys? Can you Google it? Two
experts,
UFOs, evil, and their names will come
up. Thank God for Sheth Google, the
greatest scholar ever lived. I I I have
a hard time with names.
Yeah. So, check it out in the 20th
century. Do it now. Can you Google it so
you don't think I'm lying? Brethren,
they're demons. These are the gods and
goddesses who are Satan and demons.
They'll appear However you want you want
them to be a god, they'll appear as
Krishna, Shiva, Zeus, they don't care as
long as they keep away from the Lord
Jesus Christ. Yep. So even you have a
father, is that Orthodox or Catholic?
See, so even an Orthodox father or is it
a Catholic father confirming their
demons? Yep. Interdimensional demons.
Now they'll appear as aliens because
everyone wonders in light of science
there must be other life forms in other
galaxies.
So there you go. This is what I think.
Did you guys check it? Check it. By the
way,
did you check? Okay. See, even the
Orthodox priests are seeing aliens are
real, but they're demons.
You can't deny their existence. The
evidence has now been overwhelming where
the government is getting involved.
The government now had congressional
hearings. Buddy, that tells you how
serious it is.
Just type in decodes for the third time.
Two experts, aliens, evil. Their names
will come out. Can someone do that for
me? Because I don't want to do that. So
there you go, brethren.
There you go. The Bible is clear. Satan
and demons will appear as gods and
goddesses of the ancients. And the
evidence shows it's the same demons and
Satan who now appear as aliens because
they're doing the same thing, deceiving
people into looking to them for hope and
salvation. And when people do claim to
receive information, they're promoting
new age Hinduism, not Christianity. And
people have said that when they invoke
the name of the Lord Jesus Christ, the
UFOs disappear.
Okay.
Aliens are not from the physical
universe, Lydia. Aliens are from the
spiritual dimension we call heaven.
Because that heavenly realm is not part
of the physical universe. It exists side
by side. Which is why when people die,
they see the door to that dimension open
and their spirit enters and they come
down. I've done sessions on that. So you
guys got the names right, Andreas, you
confirmed. I'm not lying. You found
their names. Next time I'll look it up.
But I just telling you this is what I
think. We're living in some exciting
times. If the aliens are now being
acknowledged as real and they're with us
and the government has alien artifacts,
objects, right? Then guess what? The gig
is up. And by the way, I forgot the
link. I gave you the link, right? Not I
forgot it. I did give you the link,
right?
Uh, go to Vlad and I'm going to show it
to you on the screen. Hold on.
And there is a series of interviews,
clips from his interview,
Dr. Steven Greer.
Let me show it. I forgot I was supposed
to open up, but anyway, you got it. It's
there. I gave you the link. So, there
you go. There you go, guys.
Had it not been so
important
that congressional hearings were not
convened to talk about it, I wouldn't
mention it. I've mentioned in the past,
but it now has gotten the attention of
the government.
God bless you, Elvis. It now got to the
congressional level where these people
are being interviewed. Hear what he
said? Yeah. Over 40 witnesses. I even
know the location where they have the
UFO object. Government knows it, right?
The military knows it.
There you go. Is that clear? Now, can we
move on?
To deny the existence of aliens is being
blind. You're sticking your head into
the sand. They're real, but they're not
aliens. They're demons. And let that
cause you to rejoice. Why? Because if
there are demons, that means your Bible
is real. That means there is a spirit
realm. Angelic creatures are real.
Spirit beings are real. Well, where did
that come from? God. Who is spirit
mountain? I don't know what they're
complicit with. I don't know if they
know or they're stupid. That's between
them and God. I don't care. Let God
judge them. I know who they are and I
know where I stand with the Lord Jesus
Christ, my Lord and Savior. May he guard
my daughters and I and all of you
covered by the blood of Jesus against
them.
Exactly. Timbo slice. By the way, Timbo,
reach out to me this week. I want to
talk to you. Okay, we got it. So, you
found them, brother. You found the name?
Oh, that's he's a Christian.
Okay. Is that you, Ross? Well, I'm the
one Christian astrophysicist that's
written on this phenomenon, but I know
of five others who spent at least a
decade studying the UFO phenomenon who
are not believers. Yep, they're real,
right?
So, Felix, you're you're confirming what
I was saying. The two leading experts,
the covert intelligence group covering
up UFOs new documentary lifts lid on
Collins Elite. Okay, so you guys
confirmed it so you don't don't think
I'm making it up. And is it ironic that
the greens, someone mentioned the
greens, they look serpentine.
They look serpentine.
They look like serpents.
Is it ironic the greens, when you look
at them, don't they resemble walking
serpents, walking snakes? Is it ironic,
brethren?
Don't they look like serpents
walking
like the ancient serpent? Yeah. And some
people say they smell like sulfur.
Exactly. Like the ancient serpent.
Yes, Gabriel. Absolutely. Shape
shifters. Not possible. They are. You
know how I know, Gabriel? Because the
Bible tells us in Hebrews 1:7,
the Bible tells us in Hebrews 1:7,
Gabriel, that God's mystering spirits,
spirit creatures
have been created with the power to
change their shape. They can appear as
flame of fire or wind or human. Yes,
Gabriel, your Bible already told you
that. Doesn't it say that Satan can also
appear as an angel of light? How if he
can't change his shape?
Yes, brethren, your Bible is miraculous,
supernatural. Like Sar Gand said, it
gave you all the wisdom to GUARD
YOURSELF. THE BIBLE tells you angelic
creatures, good or bad, can appear and
change their shape. No, not immaterial
fabric. No, wrong use of term. Please,
brother, don't let me correct you.
Okay, I'll open up the Q&A. They have
spiritual shapes because they're created
from another dimension, heaven. And
heaven is a
created reality that has space, place,
and time. But it's different from the
earth. Only God is immaterial by nature.
But just like you, check yourself out.
You changed your shape. You started as
an embryo. You developed as a fetus. And
I'm not demonizing the baby. You came
out as a baby. Then you became a
toddler, an adult. Just like your body
changes. These angels have powers where
they can change their shape, appear as
an orb of fire, appear as a man or a
woman, or appear as a serpent. They'll
appear the way you want. They can even
appear as Zeus.
Okay.
You with me there.
Exactly. Guys, when ancients record
encounters with gods and goddesses,
that's not a lie.
That's not a lie. They did see Zeus.
They did see a bow. They did see Ishtar
and Diana because they were seeing
demons appearing as Zeus. Brethren,
don't fall for the lie of the atheist
that we're all atheists except they
believe in one less god than we do. NO.
THE GODS AND GODDESSES are real. They
appear. The Bible tells you